à
donc
vous venez de le comprendre
une heure en français on dit concepteur
de jeux vidéo les deux réponses que j'ai
le plus souvent quand je les deux
réactions que j'ai le plus souvent quand
je dis ce que je fais c'est génial du
dojo jeu vidéo toute la journée ce qui
est pas tout à fait vrai et le deuxième
ce soit mais et écouter une sorte de
scénariste pour le jeu vidéo c'est pas
tout à fait ça je pense que une bonne
façon présenter ce que je fais c'est
dire que je définis ce qui est possible
pour le joueur ce qui n'est pas possible
pour lui je détermine une sorte de champ
de possibilités ou pour lui et forcément
quand on veut concevoir un jeu on veut
qu'il est un succès et pour qu'il ait le
plus de succès possible il faut
comprendre les motivations des joueurs
où c'est vraiment une dimension qui est
très importante et au final je
m'interroge mois sur les différences
qu'il peut y avoir dans les jeux que
j'ai pu jouer étant enfant et les jeux
auxquels peut jouer mon fils aujourd'hui
parce que ce serait pas un brett hawke
si on parlait pas de ses enfants et a au
final on regarde les jeux auxquels je
jouais enfance c'était les jeux qui
étaient apparues sur la première console
nintendo
le premier jeu vraiment très important
pour moi c'est mario bros et c'est un
jeu dans lequel est un objectif très
précis sauver la princesse et pour ça il
ya une méthode unique ses allées de la
gauche de l'écran vers la droite de
l'écran en sautant par dessus des
obstacles en sautant par dessus des
précipices en écrasant aussi des
adversaires
en fait c'est un jeu qui est assez
linéaire on pourrait dire dans le sens
où il ya un seul objectif et il ya une
seule véritable façon de le résoudre
c'est en passant le challenge qui sont
proposés aux joueurs c'est ça va faire
appel à sa dextérité ça fait apparaître
à ses réflexes
les jeux auquel joue mon fils son jeu
favori c'est minecraft alors c'est un
jeu peut-être que vous connaissez et
c'est un jeu dans lequel on est plongé
dans un univers composé de cubes et ses
cubes
il passe son temps à les détruire pour
récupérer des ressources que ce soit du
bois de là
hier de la terre est construit de
nouvelles choses avec il peut se
construire des outils peut se construire
des objets mais il peut aussi fabriquer
des maisons des bâtiments des ponts des
châteaux c'est un jeu qui fait vraiment
énormément appel à sa créativité
les jeux auxquels je joue aujourd'hui
sont des jeux quand même qu'ils sont
héritées de l'époque où en fait qu'ils
étaient vraiment basé sur les jeux
d'action comme un mario c'est des jeux
et qu'on appelle un monde ouvert des
jeux comme assassin's creed qu'on fait à
8 soft dans la société où je travaille
ou comme grand theft auto des jeux en
fait que ou non qu'elle y ait des
véritable challenge
mais on est passé en fait à une
ouverture avec la 3d à 360 degrés on
n'est pas sur un seul plan on a la
possibilité de naviguer où on veut et on
a des objectifs un peu partout dans le
monde et ont choisi dans quel monde on
va faire ses objectifs et souvent la
façon dont va résoudre ses objectifs
donc il ya déjà une évolution en matière
de liberté et ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que mon fils aussi jouer à
mario
il joue un nouveau mario qui a été qui
est sorti en fait cette année pour les
30 ans du personnage mario bros qui
s'appelle mario mais coeur et c'est un
jeu où au lieu de jouer directement et
d'aller sauver la princesse lui même il
va créer les niveaux de mario il devient
en fait concepteurs sont des outils qui
lui permettent de placer les blogs de
placer les ennemis et on voit la
différence qu'il a pu y avoir entre en
25 ans la différence chez un enfant de 7
ans qui va jouer en fait comme pendant
mon cas en fait aux nouveaux jeux et
pour mon fils qui lui va créer
véritablement ces niveaux donc on
s'interroge quelle différence en fait ça
peut apporter ses activités dans
laquelle on passe autant de temps étant
enfant dans les générations à venir
le temps qu'ils y passent cette
créativité qui est mise en avant
quelle est cette motivation eaux
profondes chez ses joueurs
le modèle motivation motivationnelle qui
nous intéresse et qui correspond mieux à
ça c'est celui de la théorie de
l'autodétermination qu'un modèle qui a
été développé par ryan et aider si dans
les années 70 qui identifie trois grands
axes motivationnelle le premier celui de
la maîtrise
et c'est intéressant de voir à quel
point il était présent en jeu vidéo
depuis toujours la maîtrise et de ce
fait de se sentir bien dans une activité
on progresse où on se sent fait
compétent et le jeu vidéo c'est
exactement ça c'est depuis toujours en
fait on s'améliore dans un jeu le
deuxième c'est celui de la relation et
le fait d'être en contact avec les
autres de pouvoir être utile aux autres
que les autres soient utiles à nous et
le jeu en fait à travers les jeux en
ligne avec leur apparition en fait il ya
quelques années aujourd'hui ça avait
récemment exposé en fait représente
véritablement cette dimension là mais
c'est la troisième dimension qui est
encore plus présent que jamais qui nous
intéresse c'est celle de l'autonomie
ce qu'on voit que l'autonomie dans la
théorie la motivation c'est quelque
chose qui nous permet en fait de fixer
eux mêmes les objectifs et la façon dont
va résoudre ses objectifs et dans les
jeux comme minecraft
il n'y a pas de véritablement de but à
proprement parler c'est le joueur qui se
fixe des objectifs et qui va être encore
plus inventifs pour pouvoir les résoudre
on peut s'interroger des joueurs qui
sont aussi libres
qu'est ce que ça va donner demain est-ce
qu'il ya uniquement dans le jeu vidéo
qu'on trouve ça mais non en fait on voit
que le champ des possibles c'est quelque
chose qu'on élargit à tous les niveaux
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
d'autres sources de loisirs la façon
dont je regardais la télévision mois est
enfant je choisissais la chaîne et
j'avais le programme qui correspondait à
l'horaire donné mon fils lui elle
regarde youtube il va choisir le
programme qu'il veut ou alors il a même
accès à netflix où il ya énormément de
choix le champ des possibles est énorme
pour lui on voit aussi même pour les
autres générations aujourd'hui l'accès à
la connaissance est vraiment facilité
avec des modèles que wikipédia où on
peut aller la connaissance très
facilement en suivant des liens
hypertextes si on veut rencontrer l'âme
soeur
il ya plein de possibilités sur katyn
dès aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est d'autre que d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles pour chacun
d'entre nous mais on voit aussi dans
domaines comme l'éducation dans
l'éducation on cherche de plus en plus
développée des situations où l'élève
peut être acteur de sa connaissance et
va aller vers différentes vues
différentes activités comme dans les
classes montessori
et on peut le voir aussi même en
management en management ou si on passe
de plus en plus des modèles patriarcaux
et dirigiste vers des modèles qui sont
plus d'ordre des démocratique
donc on voit en fait c'est quelque chose
qui se retrouve un peu partout il
vraiment la question peut se poser c'est
les générations qui sont élevés dans ce
contexte là qui sont élevées en jouant à
minecraft plutôt qu'en jours à mario
bros qu'est ce que ça va donner demain
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir leur proposer
on sait aussi que cette quantité de
choix ça peut générer de l' angoisse
il ya même quelque chose qu'on retrouve
régulièrement dans les jeux si jamais en
fait les jeux que je conçois propose
trop de choix des fois ça peut être
angoissant où il est même un phénomène
qu'on appelle lé analysis paralysis
quand il ya trop d'options que les
options sont pas suffisamment distingue
distinctes ça peut être bloquant aussi
pour l'action et ses lacs vraiment mon
métier en tant que game designer c'est
de prévoir ce champ des possibles et les
joueurs d'aujourd'hui demandent à avoir
un champ des possibles encore plus large
mais tout de même avec des contraintes
avec des choix intéressants qui leur
sont proposés et ses dégâts en fait une
situation classique chez nous les game
designers qui vient du concepteur de
civilisation qui s'appelle sid meier qui
dit qu'un bon jeu c'est une série de
choix intéressant et nous et vous si
vous êtes amené à proposer des produits
si vous êtes amené à proposer des
services si vous êtes amené à encadrer
les gens qu'est ce que vous allez
proposer pour des gens qui ont été
élevés avec minecraft qui ont été
habitués à voir une tellement grande
liberté avoir une plus grande autonomie
eh bien peut-être qu à vous d'être à
votre tour game designer c'est à dire à
penser à la motivation de vos
collaborateurs de vos clients de vos
élèves et à proposer en fait des espaces
de liberté en développant leur champ des
possibles plutôt qu'un modèle plus
dirigiste où on va les diriger vers une
seule offre et toute cette autonomie
c'est quelque chose dans lequel il faut
aller puiser pour pouvoir les proposer
des offres qui vous correspondent encore
mieux aux générations de demain
merci